Portia has a long history in Motorsports
it's the biggest and most successful
manufacturer in international sports car
racing and Amin machines made in
Stuttgart have a faithful following
around the world including the US the
Porsche rennsport reunion series named
after the car makers racing division has
become a pilgrimage for fans this fit
installment was hosted at the laguna
seca raceway in california in September
as always there are massive queues at
the Porsche souvenir store
yeah there's around 50,000 spectators
this year explains host Detlef von
platen there's no other event like this
in the US he reckons or perhaps the
world I love it fans can get up real
close to champion cars from yesteryear
and the men who drove them
you
lemond winner and Joakim stuck has never
seen so many Porsche enthusiasts in one
place again porsche are the only
manufacturers in the world that could
ever put on an event like this because
they've been there ever since the day
they rolled a wheel yeah Formula One
race ace Jochen mass is mightily
impressed at seeing the panic full with
beautiful cars from his time good
through the years the rent sports
festival as grow up giant Lee but what
is fascinating is the aura of Borgia
through the spectators but there is
action on the track too of course and
the drivers take no prisoners laguna
seca might have a picturesque setting
but it's a daunting course with one
particularly ominous section
one was racing legend jurgenbot says you
have to approach slowly and then you
drive around the bend with one foot held
up it's a lot of fun it's called the
corkscrew which explains pretty well how
to drive it and flutter know if not when
you know it was lots of fun at the wheel
of the current 911 rsr cup car is
factory driver gurg Bergmeister he says
Europe mostly has standard formula 1
tracks where mistakes no longer have
major consequences here in the US safety
is a bit like in the old days he says he
thinks is good if you're punished for
your mistakes jansport a man feel I'm a
bit more finished after the parade of
vintage races is a delight for the fans
and their heroes Edith me racing veteran
hands you are him stuck says it brings
back lovely memories of his first lamang
win it still gives him goosebumps
driving here and it's the highlight of
his ear well over 100 cars are entered
in the various races among them a number
of treasures from the porsche museum
associated Klaus Bischoff is the
director and he says it's always an
exciting occasion with the best cars and
the best drivers and then they're off
rolling back the years and the
kilometers and it's a thrill a minute
for the drivers the Porsche and SWAT
reunion is a unique event and reflects
the massive following Porter has in the
US
well it's really a lifestyle it's it's a
very very intense relationship but
taking my case I had a 951 and in
seattle in in minneapolis minnesota and
when we moved to Chicago the first thing
I did was to call people in Chicago from
the Porsche Club and say okay what
really what realtor do i go to see what
city should i be looking for a home and
if i want to go to dinner I'm new to the
sound weird I where do I eat and so you
it's a very very intense relationship
between the Porsche Club members all
over the country and 115,000 members in
175 clubs illustrate the intense
relationship of Americans to Porsche on
the first day the public had treated to
the premiere of the new 911 in North
America avocent starts office chief
engineer August at Lightner and his team
are proud of the new car yet again
father felt he sure everyone who drives
it will enjoy it mr. Shibata like sent
fund immortal by amethyst across besides
more power the turbocharged engines are
more efficient vinegar fuel economy is
up to twelve percent battery says which
is in keeping with the times the new 911
is already eagerly awaited in the US
yeah he says American customers don't
just go cruising down highways they take
the car out around the racetrack more
often than Germans do they really do
have the Motorsports bug soon the new
911 will be gracing the racetracks of
the us here at Laguna however it's the
blasts from the past that the fans are
focusing on at the Porsche and Sport
reunion
you